public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
guillaume pelletier vice président des
républicains donc bras droit de laurent
wauquiez est député du loir-et-cher est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
soi et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation donc merci au nom de public
sénat des échos de radio classique et de
la fpf vous répondrai au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions
notamment posé par mes confrères ici
présents ce soir jean francis pécresse
et paul briat messieurs bonsoir première
de ces questions guillaume pelletier
emmanuel macron at il raison de
maintenir le rythme des réformes ça ne
s'arrêtera pas at il prévenu deuxième
question
l'exécutif veut-il selon vous dominez le
parlement ou non dit-il de l'efficacité
de la rapidité enfin troisième question
laurent wauquiez flirt utile avec le
populisme au point d'ouvrir peut-être la
voie demain un rapprochement avec
l'extrême droite
c'est donc parti pour la première de ces
questions précédé par la déclaration des
manuels macron justement c'était ce
week-end devant devant la communauté
française en inde
nous allons continuer en france à
réformer en profondeur avec
bienveillance mais une conviction
profonde avec la certitude que notre
pays a besoin de ces transformations
pour rattraper un retard qu'il a
accumulée ces dernières décennies qui
était inexplicable pour mettre fin à un
chômage de masse auquel nous nous sommes
habitués pour mettre fin à des habitudes
qui n'avait plus de justification pour
redonner de la force avec elle la
possibilité d'être vraiment juste et
donc de la fierté à notre pays ça ne
s'arrêtera ni demain ni dans le mois
prochain ni dans les trois prochains
mois
et les françaises et les français le
souhaitent profondément seuls quelques
commentateurs fatigué voudrait qu'il y
ait un terme à ce mouvement
voilà voilà des propos qui amène la
question d'un commentateur qui n'est pas
fatigué c'est vous en dise la question
d'un cahier occultés comme péter est-ce
que emmanuel macron à raison de
maintenir le rythme effréné de ces
réformes risquent justement vous faites
partie de ces commentateurs fatigué je
pense qu'ils auraient raison si ces
réformes
était porté en profondeur il a utilisé
le mot d'ailleurs personne ne peut citer
autour de ce plateau ni même chez nos
compatriotes
une vraie réforme de structure en
profondeur emmanuel macron au fond a
choisi une autre stratégie qui est une
stratégie d'ailleurs dangereuse pour
notre pays c'est qu'à force de vouloir
aller vite il s'interdit d'aller loin il
apparaît de plus en plus moi je
l'entends dans ma circonscription de
loire et cher comme le président des
carabistouilles de c'est à dire c'est à
dire de cette illusion de cette forme de
mensonge de tromperie qui exaspère nos
compatriotes et qui ont bien compris que
chaque matin une réforme est annoncée
très vite enterré le soir et qu'à la fin
il ne reste plus grand chose
vous nous prenez au défi là parce que on
pourrais vous citer j'aimerais longue
énumération va pas rejouer cela il ya
des réformes
quand été votée ce à commencer par la
réforme du droit du travail et puis
toutes celles qui sont les juges qui
sont en mai prenant l'exemple par
exemple le on a beaucoup attendu de
cette grande réforme du droit du travail
je suis le premier à être un partisan
des petites et moyennes entreprises de
cette volonté de libérer l'économie par
exemple lié à un sujet central dont
chacun nous parle sur le terrain c'est
la question des seuils sociaux vous
savez qui pénalise beaucoup les
entreprises il y a trois fois plus
d'entreprises de 49 salariés en france
qu'il n'y en à 2,50 à cause de ce seuil
aucune réforme sur la question du droit
du travail la grande autres réformes
annoncées après je m'arrêterai là tout
au long de l'automne trois mois de
communication gouvernementale sur le
sujet la hausse attendue est promise du
pouvoir d'achat est depuis janvier
chaque français quelle qu'ait été son
vote au printemps dernier a bien vu et
compris
très concrètement que cette promesse
n'était pas tenu et que c'était une
carabistouilles de plus c'est à dire que
4,5 milliards de nouveaux impôts je ne
parle même pas des retraités qui paye
lourdement et un lourd tribut à la
politique d' emmanuel macron et je ne
parle même pas des classes moyennes et
habitants des territoires ruraux
on y reviendra probablement donc pour
reprendre la réforme du baccalauréat qui
est une véritable réforme qui traînait
depuis
des années et des années que la droite
ni la gauche je n'avais fait qu'il a
fait on peut on pourrait prendre toute
une série de réformes comme disons que
sur celle ci elle est annoncée
oui je suis un membre de la commission
éducation culture à l'assemblée
nationale on a évidemment écouté
beaucoup le ministre de l'éducation
nationale il est en train de la préciser
de l'annoncé elle n'est pas encore
entérinée et voter et sur la question de
l'école qui est une question ô combien
centrale dans notre république
je retienne plutôt une chose c'était il
ya quelques mois ici au sénat le
président de l'assemblée nationale m'a
désigné avec 9 de mes pairs comme
représentant de l'assemblée nationale à
la conférence nationale des territoires
et nous avons reçu emmanuel macron ici
le 17 juillet 2017 c'était en fin de
matinée emmanuel macron a eu ces mots
très clair sur l'école les territoires
ruraux ne doivent plus être la variable
d'ajustement points il n'y aura aucune
fermeture de classe dans les écoles
rurales points fermez les guillemets
sept mois après sept mois après nouvelle
carabistouilles mille classes ont été
fermées dans nos écoles rurales quand il
ya plus de leur maintien les cloches je
ne dis pas qu ici ou là il faut bien sûr
nous sommes désolés réalité qu'une envie
c'est pas vrai je suis parent vous le
savez élus de loire et cher il y aura
une dizaine d'ouvertures de classes dans
la grande capitale départementale blois
pour une trentaine de fermeture dans des
classes d'écoles rurales alors même
qu'il ya une relative stabilité des
effectifs mieux car horizon deux ans ou
trois ans grâce à l'arrivée des jeunes
familles nous savons qu'il y aura des
augmentations démographique la vision d'
emmanuel macron sur la question de
l'école sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat sur la question des territoires
c'est une vision au fond très
hégémonique très jacobine et très
distendue vis-à-vis du peuple
alors quand même on nous présente
toujours ont le regard de l'étranger
comme le président réformateur à vous
nous dites c'est le président des
carabistouilles oui vous êtes allés
chercher ce mot non non c'est un mot que
j'entends vos coups que je dis souvent
en soleil un mot emprunté de la belgique
qui signifie cette ce mélange entre
tromperie et mensonges et on est
vraiment là dedans c'est très correct et
je peux vous dire quand j'écoute
emmanuel macron je suis le premier à
être intéressés à être attentifs
j'aime trop mon pays pour ne pas
souhaiter la réussite des manuels macron
je place au dessus de mon parti mon pays
au dessus de mon parti le bien commun et
l'intérêt général et tout ce qui a été
ou est dans le bon sens je le
soutiendrai il m'est arrivé ici ou là de
voter des réformes à l'assemblée
nationale mais je n'accepte pas au nom
du peuple français
qu'ont ils usent yonne nos compatriotes
par une addition de mots sans jamais
agir
il y avait une sartre disait au
commencement était le verbe disait ton
nom au commencement était l'action est
bien chez emmanuel macron l'action
véritable profondes structurelles on a
le retrouve jamie dont on a vu une telle
qu'il ya quand même des réformes ou des
projets de réformes contre lesquelles
l'opposition est vendu 10 je pense
notamment à la réduction de la vitesse
sur route secondaire des républicains
ont lancé ce matin une campagne pour
protester contre ce ce projet tanner est
ce que c'est vraiment digne d'un grand
parti d'opposition que de que d'être
contre une réforme qui a pour objectif
de baisser la mortalité sur les routes
bien sûr parce que là encore nous sommes
très attachés à la vérité nous sommes
tous sur ce plateau et l'ensemble des
formations politiques en tout cas la
mienne de manière très claire attaché à
lutter contre la mortalité routière et
être des défenseurs acharnés de la
sécurité routière mer et durée vitesse
c'est notre manière de baisser la
mortalité semis ou deux ans à 400 vies
sauvées par an nous dit on nous dit on
nous dit on soyons très précis emmanuel
macron d'abord c'est une promesse trahie
puisque lors de la campagne
présidentielle avait dit on ne pourra
pas imposé d'en haut
la règle des 80 km/heure à l'ensemble
des routes françaises chacun sait qu'il
est des routes ou les 90 km/heure
d'hôtes les 70 km/heure devront
s'appliquer ce que nous proposons nous
avec laurent wauquiez est très clair et
très simple et très pragmatique
nous souhaitons d'abord confier la
responsabilité de la limitation de
vitesse ou au président département où
homer j'ai été maire d'une commune
rurale nous sommes les mieux à même de
bien connaître la dangerosité de tel ou
tel tronçon de route premièrement
deuxièmement nous regardons ce qui se
passe à l'étranger
l'exemple danois par exemple qui n'est
pas le seul tend à démontrer que ça
n'est pas la baisse de la mortalité
n'est pas forcément lié à la réduction
de la vitesse mais ce qui est certain et
chacun le sait qu'est ce qui est
dangereux aujourd'hui sur nos routes
les comportements à risque l'alcool la
drogue le téléphone il nous faut être
rétabli la vitrine certainement des
comporte l'un des dangers mais pas le
seul
en tout cas pas s'il s'applique de
manière automatique à l'ensemble des
routes vous avez 400 mille kilomètres de
routes secondaires sur le territoire
national quelle est la première raison
de la mortalité
c'est le mauvais entretien de notre
réseau secondaire il nous faut donc il
faut que l'état ait le courage de dire
nous allons attribuer des moyens
supplémentaires aux départements pour
mieux entretenir les routes de nos
territoires en france même la sécurité
routière qui était un des grands
chantiers du président chirac qui était
un grand chantier de la droite
elle fait partie de ces chantiers qui au
départ seront forcément impopulaires
comme la lutte contre l'alcoolisme et on
a le sentiment que vous êtes peut-être
pas dans une posture de responsabilité
en tant que responsable de l'option sur
sur ce sujet lâchement vous avez
d'ailleurs j'ai répondu beaucoup de
précision et j'essaye d'étendre le sujet
je le redis pour qu'il soit très clair
et c'est la position que nous portons
avec laurent wauquiez il est hors de
question de faire de ce sujet un sujet
secondaire ou tertiaire
c'est vraiment un sujet premier parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit de s'amuser ou de
jouer avec la sécurité routière
mais le gouvernement non plus en faisant
croire qu'une seule mesure très
cosmétique et trade marketing
permettrait de régler l'ensemble du
problème
nous disons au gouvernement prenez vos
responsabilités venez en aide aux
départements qui entretiennent les
routes secondaires et ayez une politique
très globale pourquoi s'en prendre
systématiquement aux automobilistes
honnête pourquoi par exemple briser un
rapport 5 % des accidents mortels en
france sont commis par un pour cent des
automobilistes c'est à dire ceux qui
n'ont pas d'assurance
or les sanctions les contrôles sont très
insuffisants sur ce sujet là alors autre
sujet je suis surpris quand même de vous
entendre dire que emmanuel mâcon ne va
pas assez loin pourquoi parce que c'est
le reproche qu'on faisait à nicolas
sarkozy en son temps on va prendre un
cas lié sef la réforme jsf c'était l'une
de ses mesures emblématiques que nicolas
sarkozy devait abattre
il ne l'a pas fait et c'est emmanuel
macron qui le fait est là vous dit il
il ne va pas assez loin et c'est ce qui
va pas quand même une forme non
contradiction dont votre propos c'est
quoi le grand combat dès la nouvelle
génération à droite
c'est où on fait de la politique
politicienne et ça n'a aucun sens ça
nous mène 30 ans après la situation
d'aujourd'hui où on essaye sur chacun
des sujets d'aller au fond en profondeur
de tracer une perspective vont parler la
question de l' isf et vous avez raison
c'est un sujet d'un impôt idiot
chacun sait qu il coûte plus qu'il ne
rapporte à l'état qui fait partir un
certain nombre des nôtres à l'étranger
mais disons la vérité aux français
et est-ce légitime était équilibré était
ce juste que de supprimer l' isf pour
les spéculateurs les détenteurs de
capitaux et maintenir l' isf pour les
propriétaires de patrimoine immobilier
bien sûr que non et donc ce que nous
disons nous c'est que la politique d'
emmanuel macron est une politique à
l'endroit d'une seule partie des
français au fond emmanuel macron c'est
le président de l'injustice sociale et
de l'injustice territoriale la justice
territoriale
vous avez bien un peu dit le président
des riches volent dit non parce que je
ne veux pas opposer la société française
mais c'est un président de l'injustice
elle est sociale elle et territoriales
elle est sociale sur la question dit sfl
et social sur un autre sujet dans le
même alors quand alors qu'eux ils
baissent ils augmentent la csg pour nous
les retraités alors qu'il augmente la
fiscalité d'un grand nombre de ménages
je pense entre autres aux familles
il supprime 300 millions de taxe
exceptionnelle sur les hauts salaires
dans les banques et les assurances
emmanuel macron a une vision très étroit
de la société française et s'adresse
uniquement à ceux qui vont très bien
alors notre sondage opinionway pour
l'épreuve de vérité la première question
portait sur les réformes donc est ce que
vous estimez que emmanuel macron tient
ses promesses c'est bien il ya un oui
quand même assez massif un gameplay à
55% non 42% tout de même mais les
électeurs de droite approuvent
massivement disent oui plus de 60% et il
réforme comme il l'avait annoncé
vous êtes un peu non non je vais pas une
ride pris il ya d'abord il a fait 65 %
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
il a déjà une perte assez nette
et puis si tous les français qui ont été
interrogés par cet institut
regardez l'émission depuis le
nous avons pensé à une pédagogie je suis
sûr qu'ils leur changerait la vie
pourquoi on a parlé du pouvoir d'achat
promet ce trail des écoles du monde
rural
on pourrait aussi parler de la question
de l'immigration beaucoup d'annoncés
beaucoup d' esbroufe et au fond pas
grand chose il n'y a pas chez emmanuel
macron de volonté solide et durable de
réformer ou nous redit que le mot le mot
le président des arabistes houllier
faire abuser deuxième partie maintenant
te fait paul vous allez avoir la parole
dans trente secondes car c'est l'heure
de la deuxième partie avec la deuxième
question ont révoqué le reproche qui est
adressé au gouvernement actuellement
l'autoritarisme vis-à-vis du parlement
[Musique]
paul c'est à vous même puisque selon
vous exécutif veut véritablement dominer
le parlement c'est une critique qui est
régulièrement formulées à l'endroit de
l'exécutif c'est comme ça que vous que
vous percevez je suis un jeune député
j'ai été élu en juin
je trouve que nos institutions ont
permis à la france de traverser des
épreuves lourdes et parfois violentes et
je suis très marqué oui par cette
volonté très centralisatrice très
jacobine je dirais même très hégémonique
que porte
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
c'est pas de chance de la sortie de
république cette hégémonie sme ce n'est
pas ce que nous ce qu'on voulait leur
président sarkozy l'autorité oui
l'autoritarisme dont vous parlez de
nicolas sarkozy quelle fut la grande
réforme constitutionnelle de nicolas
sarkozy au fond quand on parle de
constitution et parlement il ya deux
solutions où on augmente les droits de
l'opposition
c'était le cas nicolas sarkozy l'a
confié par exemple la présidence de la
commission des finances à l'opposition
il a permis sans certain nombre de
nominations a droit de veto du parlement
il a renoncé aux ordonnances sur la
réforme des retraites en 2010 nicolas
sarkozy est un président plein d'énergie
plein d'autorité mais pas dans
l'autoritarisme emmanuel mac on voyait
bien dans son rapport au peuple français
au salon agriculture aux journalistes
encore aujourd'hui à travers une réponse
assez sèche quand on met en cause sa
politique et dans sa grande vision du
parlement j'avais vu mois début juillet
a été très marquée au congrès à
versailles lorsqu'il était devant nous
il y avait une vision et des mots très
durs à l'endroit du parlement puis le
renier les droit d'amendement des
parlementaires ce qui est extrêmement
préoccupant c'est un droit fondamental
des parlementaires le groupe majoritaire
en marche à l'assemblée nationale n'a
toujours pas le droit de co signé des
amendements venant d'autres bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
donc oui emmanuel macron au fond a un
problème avec le peuple français et je
dirais avec l'opposition avec les corps
intermédiaires tout l' inverse de ce que
nous portons avec laurent wauquiez nous
ne considérons que les élus locaux que
la force du parlement c'est
indispensable
et quand on est fort quand on est fiers
quand on est solide et quand on est
certain on n'a pas peur de donner
davantage de droits à son opposition on
va écouter sur ce sujet christophe
castaner le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement et déléguée
générale de la république en marche il
explique pourquoi il est nécessaire de
rénover également les pratiques du
parlement ça
comme moi qu'il faut en moyenne deux ans
entre le début d'un texte et son
aboutissement les français ne vivent pas
ce rythme là donc il faut se donner les
moyens du contrôle et les amendements de
l'évolution les amendements en font
partie mais il faut aussi que le
parlement on retrouve une volonté
d'efficacité de rapidité et une capacité
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement
parce que parmi les mesures que nous
mettons en avant c'est aussi de
renforcer les droits de contrôle du
parlement qu'il n'utilise pas assez
aujourd'hui alors que répondez vous à
cela
ces déclarations rénover notre
démocratie parlementaire
mais pour valeurs d'efficacité c'est le
maquereau nisme une addition de jolis
mots auquel tout le monde peut adhérer
mais au fond une réforme la brutale sur
la question brutale du parlement en même
temps il d'un vérin caché puisque dès sa
campagne électorale il avait annoncé une
réduction du nombre de parlementaires le
une dose de proportionnelle et la fin du
cumul dans le temps des mandats au moins
pour les principaux élus donc il n'a
rien cacher pourquoi est-ce-que boutique
brutale bah non mais sur ce sujet là je
suis totalement d'accord avec vous il
avait annoncé un certain nombre de
réformes
les mots utilisés l'attitude la volonté
non annoncés pour le coup de restreindre
les droits d'un an non d'un
parlementaire et puis ce manque de
pragmatisme
que se passe-t-il en europe de
l'allemagne à l'italie on voit bien que
la proportionnelle a des conséquences
lourdes sur la capacité à un goût d'un
gouvernement d'être stable dans le temps
on l'a bien vu en italie devons attendre
plusieurs semaines avant d'avoir un
gouvernement vous êtes s'est opposé à
même une dose de 25 % par exemple comme
on le veut j'essaie d'être subtil et
prendre le temps jeu juste et
d'expliquer quelle est ma vision d'une
audition sur une question on garde ce
qui est effectivement permis la
stabilité de la vème république il y ait
à la marge une dose de proportionnelle
c'est con prof marge de 10% séquence
pourri de 10% me semble être le maximum
franchement même si j'entends très bien
ce que dit christian jacob en disant que
c'est ouvrir la boîte de pandore mais je
voudrais aller plus loin ce qui
m'inquiète dans cette réforme c'est là
le mépris et la méconnaissance profonde
que porte emmanuel macron à l'endroit
des territoires ruraux chacun sait que
la réforme constitutionnelle
la baisse du nombre de parlementaires va
conduire à une sous représentation des
territoires ruraux
il ya des départements le jura la haute
loire
encore après la lozère par exemple comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui qui finirait
avec un seul député aujourd'hui un
député c'est 100 à 120 mille électeurs
dont nous nous occupons au quotidien
demain ce serait deux cent mille c'est à
dire on ne verrait plus personne n'est
plus personne n'aura le temps de nous
rencontrer et de nous voir donc je veux
bien moins une réduction du nombre de
parlementaires à contribuer comme à la
condition que le gouvernement s'engage à
une forme de discrimination positive à
l'endroit des territoires ruraux
éloignés pour que on rééquilibre la
représentation dans notre pays
premièrement deuxièmement je souhaite
moi parce que arrêtons d'être démagogue
que le maire de lyon le maire de
marseille le maire de paris ne puisse
pas cumuler avec un mandat de
parlementaire me semble profondément
légitime
j'étais maire d'une commune rurale nous
avons droit nous les élus les habitants
du monde rural au respect du pouvoir
central et donc il n'est pas
inintéressant que les maires des
communes rurales puissent cumuler avec
un mandat de parlementaire pour
justement ouvrir des portes que nous
avons d'habitude davantage de mal à
pouvoir ouvrir enfin la pratique central
du référendum doit être davantage
nourris dans notre pays
quoi de mieux pour reprendre les mots de
monsieur castanet rousse de monsieur
macron peu qu'ils veulent et qui
prétendent réconcilier la politique avec
le peuple français quoi de mieux que de
savoir consulter davantage que ne l'ont
fait ses prédécesseurs
pendant les trente dernières années le
peuple français sur des sujets centraux
est important il y en a un qui agite
beaucoup nos compatriotes aujourd'hui à
travers la sncf à travers la série c'est
la question des retraites
nous nous plaidons pour l'alignement
public-privé de toutes les retraites et
la fin de tous les régimes spéciaux
voilà un gros grand et beau sujet de
référendum pour permettre au peuple
français de s'emparer de son avenir et
de régler définitivement un sujet dont
on sait qu'ils agitent et abîme beaucoup
la classe politique alors des réseaux
protégés contre les hausses de la cg
pour les retraites avec cette politique
là vous allez faire des perdants vous le
savez un ballet qu'elle amène certains
agents du service public
je crois qu'au nom de la justice il est
pas grave vous l'assumez j'ai été chef
d'entreprise et fonctionnaires puisque
mon premier métier fut d'être professeur
d'histoire géographie en collèges et
lycées publics
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi en tant que
fonctionnaire j'avais droit à 75 % de ma
retraite sur les six derniers mois
et pourquoi en tant que salarié du privé
j'avais droit à 50%
25 meilleures années je crois l'idéal de
justice la droite de demain se d'odette
la droite de la justice sociale et au
nom de cet idéal justice il nous faut un
régime unique de retraites ces
progressions de carrière ne sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes dans le secteur
public et dans cette série il faut pas
il faudra est libre et bien surpris par
votre propre majorité entre 2007 et 2012
pour aligner ces régimes il reste plus
grand-chose à faire d'ailleurs
prenons l'exemple de la sncf vous savez
que chaque année le spécial c'est pas la
france vous savez chaque année que le
peuple français fait un chèque de 3
milliards 200 millions d'euros à la sncf
pour équilibrer les régimes de retraite
et payer les retraites des cheminots ce
recours au référendum que vous évoquez
vous le souhaitez également pour la
réforme constitutionnelle
c'est une bonne manière de trancher à
votre avis à jeudi au président de la
république fiche d'accord allez-y
puisqu'il ils agitent cette menace et
sept armes depuis plusieurs semaines
comme un ultime mépris à l'endroit du
parlement d'abord le jeu wii du sénat
mais même de l'assemblée nationale il a
un peu de problèmes avec les
parlementaires
quel qu'il soit moi je souhaite un que
le parlement soit pleinement associés à
cette réforme et que le sénat comme
l'assemblée nationale soit respectée
intimement profondément respecté mais si
le présent république veut contourner
l'immense fonction parlementaire alors
qu'il aille au peuple et nous saurons
rappeler au peuple français à l'occasion
de ce grand référendum sur les
institutions et sur la france des
territoires combien toute la politique
d' emmanuel macron vise à mépriser et à
abîmer les territoires la ruralité la
france oublier la france périphérique et
je ne suis pas certain on verra qu'il
soit en capacité alors de remporter ce
référendum est ce que pour vous le
président du sénat gérard larcher et
l'homme qui saura dire non à emmanuel
macron dans ce débat qui est engagée en
tout cas je lui sais gré de porter avec
beaucoup de vigueur et de force le c'est
un solognot qui le dit
j'ai la chance de le connaître un peu
gérard larcher il aime beaucoup la
sologne de porter avec force cette
vision d'une égalité des territoires la
république c'est le sait la république
sur tout le territoire de la république
et on ne peut pas avoir une vision
uniquement parisienne de la france et du
monde
paris a son importance paris c'est la
capitale de la france mais on est très
loin du pacte girondins emmanuel macron
c'est le celui qui réhabilite une vision
très archaïque du jacobinisme à la
française où tout se prend les décisions
a quelques-uns entre lui-même et avec de
vrais pouvoirs et techno travail se
sentent visant le chef de l'état sur son
mépris ce que vous ne tenez pas d'une
certaine manière ces fractures
françaises
non je le grand combat que j'essaye de
me neri avec une immense sincérité c'est
l'égalité des territoires
emmanuel macron a décidé je le regrette
et j'espère qu'il se reprendra je lui
demande de se reprendre a décidé depuis
le début de son quinquennat d'être un
président qui divise le peuple français
qui divise les territoires toute sa
politique vous savez je pourrais vous
parler du diesel du fuel de la csg des
écoles du monde rural des lignes des
petites lignes comme ils disent à paris
nous que nous avons les grandes lignes
du quotidien des travailleurs dans nos
dans nos territoires
les agriculteurs 1400 commune qui se
voient privés de des zones de difficile
oui bien sûr qu'il y en a qui permette
qui leur permet l'union des communes
gagnante supérieur vous le savez il ya
une balance qui profite le plus de
communes
non mais c'est toujours les mêmes moi je
le dis on a remporté une victoire en
sologne
on a pu maintenir le statut des
agriculteurs en gds et ça c'est une
victoire mais dans toute la région
centre val de loire
des centaines et des centaines
d'agriculteurs sont aujourd'hui démunis
on ne peut pas vous le savez bien
réformé l'agriculture et des fds sans
avoir une vision globale de
l'agriculture sur les circuits de
proximité sur la diversification des
revenus sur le maintien d'une politique
agricole commune totalement à prix
constants d'une part et réhabiliter
autour des prix rémunérateurs donc
emmanuel macron a décidé de de saccades
et ses réformes et de les saccades et au
service d'une minorité de français tout
en méprisant
profondeur une majorité de français je
le dis c'est lui qui divise nous notre
volonté c'est de réconcilier et de
réunifier la france et j'espère qu'ils
le feront dans le métier dans la
question de michel grossiord il ya quand
même une question de fond qui est très
important qui a trait à la stratégie de
l'opposition à la stratégie du grand
parti droite que vous prétendez
reconstruire c'est au fond l'image que
vous renvoyez d'un parti qui défend la
france qui souffre la france des
territoires perdus la france des de ces
usines qui ferment la france des paysans
qui souffrent or traditionnellement la
droite en france est plutôt une droite
qui prône le libéralisme une forme 2
d'ouverture au monde d'ouverture à la
mondialisation et vous on a le sentiment
que vous êtes en train de renverser le
schéma totalement vous n'avez pas tort
et je les assume
si la droite de demain continue à
s'enfermer dans une vision statistiques
et comptables du monde où seul le pib où
le taux de tva compte alors elle ne
retrouvera jamais les responsabilités ça
ne veut pas dire attendez ça ne veut pas
dire que je ne marche pas sur deux
jambes et que laurent wauquiez ne marche
pas sur deux jambes
nous sommes attachés à l'idéal de
liberté à la liberté d'entreprise à la
réforme du syndicalisme à la réforme des
retraites vous m'avez entendu tout à
l'heure ça n'est pas un propos
profondément anti libérale je suis
attaché à cette valeur de la liberté
il y aurait tant d'autres choses à dire
je j'aime les métropoles
je suis attaché aux grandes villes je
crois profondément on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure sur la question
européenne pour les républicains
à la question de l'intelligence
artificielle et comment l'europe se
modernise donc nous avons cette partie
là bien entendu mais trop longtemps on
entend permet trop longtemps oui mais
parce que trop longtemps
la droite a oublié une grande partie de
l'essentiel c'est à dire d'être le grand
mouvement populaire de la france
silencieuse est majoritaire et nous
devons parler à ces français qui
souffrent c'est un peu le discours du fn
je ne vous fais pas de procès mais c'est
un peu le discours on va en parler dans
un instant à la majorité silencieuse
c'est ce que vous êtes si l'état fait de
l'événement vous venez de vous savez
c'était les mots du général de gaulle
c'était les mots de tant d'autres et ça
fait trop longtemps
marion j'avais beaucoup étaient marqués
et passionné par la campagne
présidentielle de nicolas sarkozy par
son quinquennat et depuis cinq ans la
droite a oublié de parler aux
fonctionnaires elle doit devoir parler
aux fonctionnaires la droite a oublié de
parler aux immigrés des quartiers
populaires je souhaite que la droite ne
parle aux émigrés des quartiers
populaires je souhaite que la droite
emplois nouveaux
ce joli mot abandonné la gauche des
travailleurs nous devons être le grand
mouvement des entrepreneurs certes mais
des travailleurs car au sein d'une
entreprise on a besoin des deux des
entrepreneurs et des salariés d'aller
une dernière question sur cette
thématique exigeant via huit paires
jacobinisme que vous dénonciez est ce
que ça veut dire que vous êtes favorable
à l'inscription de la corse dans la
constitution en tant que entité
spécifique
là encore je trouve que c'est une vision
très marketing de la république apporte
emmanuel magna constitution quand même
oui mais justement si de dur j'inscris
vous inscrire pas quel est le même
nos propositions sur la question corse
un de rappeler de manière forte que la
corse et la république et la corse et la
france mais d'être profondément ouverts
en même temps comme dirait manuel macron
avec la défense la promotion de
l'identité corse ont inscrit ou inscrits
pas maintenant je considère que
l'article 72 qui permet vous savez un
certain nombre d'expérimentations des
territoires suffit largement
je souhaite d'ailleurs que ce droit à
l'expérimentation je le réclame pour mon
territoire soit élargie soit pérennisée
mais la corse et la république à égalité
des autres territoires ça ne veut pas
dire compte tenu de sa spécificité et je
suis moi même très sensible et très
attaché à l'identité corse parme à la
langue corse qui doit être portée
défendu et sauvegardé par la république
française
allez troisième partie de l'épreuve de
vérité troisième question sur une
thématique à un petit peu déjà abordé
jean-francis qui pose la question donc
de secondes continue
[Musique]
jean-francis cet amour question simple
est ce que laurent wauquiez ne flirte
pas un peu avec le populisme
mais là encore vous savez on avait posé
la même question emmanuel macron pendant
la campagne présidentielle pour vous
souhaiter c'était le goût de mémoire sur
france 2 ils avaient répandu la manière
suivante avec beaucoup de justesse
emmanuel macron il avait dit s'y être
populiste sait flatter les bas instincts
du peuple alors c'est une faute et la
raison mais si être populiste c'est
parler directement aux français qui
souffrent aux catégories populaires aux
ouvriers aux employés aux fonctionnaires
aux immigrés à tous ces français qui ont
du mal à se faire entendre et qu'ils
sont considérés aujourd'hui comme des
sans voix ou des citoyens de seconde
zone
alors nous devons revendiquer le mot que
j'ai choisi moi de populaire vous savez
sur un développement audika j'ai fondé
les populaires c'est-à-dire tout en
rejetant évidemment une le populisme
caricatural cette volonté de fonder la
droite française sur des valeurs de bon
sens et des valeurs populaires en
portant les aspirations profondes de
ceux qui ont moins et de ce que le
président la république ne considère
comme des gens qui ne sont rien pour
reprendre son goût alors mais vous avez
noté que marine le pen elle vous écoute
et le diberder c'est mon discours ce
sont mes mots et qu après mes idées
voilà ce que l'entente est là moi depuis
mon engagement politique en plus vouvry
revenir j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
et je ne me positionne jamais je me lève
pas le matin en me disant tiens qu'est
ce que pense emmanuel macron jean luc
mélenchon marine le pen avec laurent
wauquiez avec virginie calmels ce avec
damien abad
nous voulons refonder la droite
française et revenir aux responsabilités
en 2022
et pour ce faire nous assumons
totalement de regarder ce qui a marché
chez nous et ce qui n'a pas marché chez
nous notre position vis à vis du front
national est d'une clarté absolue vous
la connaissez il n'y a pas et il n'y
aura pas d'accord avec le front national
pour un certain nombre de raisons nous
avons tiré maria 10 milliards membres
des républicains ils l'ont et qui hier a
après un rapprochement à une alliance
avec le front national
thierry mariani ne fait pas partie de
l'équipe dirigeante on n'a jamais
interdit au sein des républicains à qui
que ce soit d'avoir sa propre opinion à
moi de le dire il a besoin de le dire
mais tout le monde a le droit de tout
dire
heureusement
compris de dire tout ce qu'on vient
cette fois-ci il ya beaucoup de gens
chez nous qui ont dit cet été dernier il
faut une alliance avec emmanuel macron
bon il ya ceux qui l'ont dit pas tout à
fait ce qu'il veut c'est pas tout à fait
même chose mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle 1 mais notre position est très
poussée on peut faire une jolie cas et
dire il faut s'allier au front national
en mai c'est un non sujet pourquoi nous
sommes 300 mille adhérents
nous sommes le premier parti de france
nous avons 100 députés nous avons la
majorité au sénat je veux bien qu'on
analyse les propos de telle ou telle
quelle est la ligne officielle claire et
définitive de laurent wauquiez et des
républicains pas d'accord avec le front
national pour autant nous revendiquons
n'ont pas le droit mais le devoir de
nous adresser à tous les électeurs parce
que si nous voulons redevenir
majoritaire nous revendiquons ce devoir
de nous adresser aux électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon de monsieur macron de 2017
et de madame le pen bien entre madame le
pen on va l'écouter
hier à lille puisqu'il a beaucoup
développé le thème des alliances et
c'est nouveau quand même dans sa bouche
en les côtes
nous devons mettre en oeuvre des
alliances parce que sous la vème
république qui repose sur un mode de
scrutin à deux tours gagnés sans
alliance est ardue
[Applaudissements]
nous l'avons vu aux régionales alors n'a
pas envie de revivre les régionales
alors qu'est-ce que vous êtes sensible
un peu à cette musique est ce que selon
vous le changement de nom du front
national a une incidence non mais soyons
sérieux que le front national s'appelle
rassemblement rassemblement national
c'est comme si le le parti communiste
s'appelait demain le grand party la
démocratie et la liberté
personne n'y croit bien sûr que le front
national n'est pas un parti de
rassemblement
marine le pen l'a démontré lors du débat
raté du second tour face à emmanuel
macron sa vision de l'europe
sortie de l'europe est sortie de l'euro
sa vision de la france à travers la
préférence nationale et ses facilités de
langage sur le constat où la critique
l'art est difficile la critique est
facile
le front national est un parti de la
critique systématique où sont les
propositions sérieuses et solide le
peuple français est un peuple solide et
intelligent qui sait très bien faire la
part des choses entre des gens qui agit
des chiffons rouges et des gens qui
essaient de travailler sereinement
concrètement à l'élaboration de mesures
audacieuses pour la france j'ai parlé
d'un certain nombre de mesures
audacieuses sur la question des
retraites
je pourrais le faire sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat nous l'avons fait avec
laurent wauquiez sur la question de
l'immigration nous voulons plus de
fermeté sur le territoire national mais
nous voulons je le revendique
j'ai proposé en premier cette idée de
créer avec les élections européennes un
grand plan marshall avec l'afrique au
nom du co développement
tout ceci sur la question des migrations
qui vous disent que ce problème sera
réglé à l'aune de loi plus ou moins
fermes sur le territoire national manque
de justesse ou de hauteur de vue
il y aura 2 milliard d'africains en 2050
la première cause de l'immigration c'est
la misère et la détresse des pays du sud
voilà un grand et beau projet européen
pourrait conseiller les peuples avec
l'idéal européen que de proposer
l'occasion des élections européennes qui
ont dû malgré un grand plan avec
contrepartie bien sûr création d'état
civil formation j'aimerais bien
d'ailleurs le doublé d'un service
civique européen pour blaye la jeunesse
européenne puis si ce sera aussi la
fermeture totale des frontières
non ce serait par exemple les laissez
passer consulaires la volonté pour les
pays africains de
d'accueillir celles et ceux qui n'ont
pas vocation à rester sur le territoire
national parce qu'ils ne respectent pas
nos lois
repensez à égalité une vision équilibrée
entre l'europe et l'afrique
quelle est la ligne rouge qui vous
sépare du fn et qui empêche aujourd'hui
de faire une alliance
est-ce que c'est simplement la question
de la sortie de l'euro non je voulais
dit tout à l'heure
il ya bien sûr c'est une question
essentielle la sortie de l'euro et de
l'europe qui ne figurent pas du tout à
notre programme et qui sont évidemment
les deux une folie il ya la question de
la préférence nationale c'est à dire de
cette vision la société française mais
la clause molière dans la région rhône
alpes par exemple c'est cette obligation
faite aux travailleurs de parler le
français sur mes salariés c'est une
forme de préférence non non ça n'a rien
à voir régional gelé moi aussi proposé
dans ma dans ma région pourquoi parce
que l'on sait très bien les dégâts et
les ravages que constituent les excès de
la directive sur le travail détachés
dans notre pays et pour les entreprises
françaises et pour des questions de
sécurité qu'on impose la langue
française sur les marchés à travers les
marchés publics réalisés par nos
collectivités
c'est du bon sens qu'on ait une vision
dans tous les domaines lee exclusivement
à la préférence nationale
c'est très préoccupant et c'est une
différencie du front national et on va
même beaucoup plus loin
le programme économique du front
national est un programme de
l'ultra-gauche son incapacité à
rassembler les outrances verbales les
outrances d'attitude comme on l'a vu
encore ce week-end avec un des
assistants parlementaires de madame le
pen
on voit bien que tous en tout cas
beaucoup de choses nous différencie du
front national et moi je fais une grande
différence entre le parti front national
et les électeurs français je ne suis pas
de ceux qui considèrent les électeurs du
front national comme des citoyens de
seconde zone
il mérite le respect et égalité comme
tous les électeurs de la république et
notre défi avec laurent wauquiez c'est
de nous adresser à tous les électeurs
français quelle qu'ait été leur choix et
ce alors vous parlez des électeurs du
front national y également les militants
paul vous étiez à lille ce week end ne
vous avait notamment assisté au discours
de steve banane qui a été acclamé
lorsqu'il a parlé notamment du racisme
et de la xénophobie que les militants du
front national doit assumer absolument
ça vous choque ce genre de propos ce
type banane ex-conseiller de de trump
dit
si on vous traite de raciste de
xénophobe le porter comme un étendard
finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire
alors il a été très applaudi monsieur
bonhomme dans les rangs du front
national sa veux dire quoi est-ce que
les populismes et sont en train de
gagner l'europe à ce que le tram piste
mais en train de gagner l'europe c'est
comme ça que vous analysez j'ai passé
des analyses comme ça entretient n'a dit
que trump d'inspirer de george aurait pu
ajouter à la litanie que j'ai utilisé
tout à l'heure à la en répondant à jean
francis pécresse
cette intervention absurde dangereuse
contraire à tout ce en quoi nous croyons
de monsieur ban ki tréportais presse
comme un étendard la xénophobie et le
racisme
chez nous la xénophobie et le racisme
c'est non c'est dix fois non c'est mille
fois non il n'ya même pas de débat et on
voit bien chez les dirigeants du front
national ces difficultés cette ambiguïté
est bien chez nous il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté et donc je le répète la
question d'une alliance avec le front
national
c'est un non sujet il n'y aura pas
d'accord mais nous revendiquons
al'inverse contrairement une grande
partie la classe politique a préféré
mener une politique de l'autruche sur le
sujet prendre tous les sujets abandonné
pourquoi laisser l'idéal de la patrie de
la nation de la lutte contre
l'immigration excessive
la dichotomie mondialistes nationaux
c'est ce que dit marine le pen c'est ce
que dit aussi monsieur bah nan c'est une
bonne dichotomie c'est un mondialiste
nationaux c'est un bon débat sain bon
clivages il ya plein de clivage qui
transmet macy gray ce que vous êtes
plutôt est ce que vous êtes vous
définissez comme nationale ou comme
mondialistes
moi je suis un patriote universel un
patriote républicain ça veut dire quoi
que la devise qui fonde mon engagement
politique
ce sont des racines et des ailes c'est à
dire parce que je suis fier de ce que je
suis de l'histoire de mon pays de
l'histoire de mon peuple de ses parts de
lumière et de ses parts d'ombré alors
j'ai l'audace et l' envie de m'ouvrir au
monde d'accueillir l'autre et de
démontrer à l'universel que la france
retrouve sa vocation d' équilibre c'est
très différent mais je suis patriote
mais à patriotes républicains universel
alors le populisme c'était le thème de
notre deuxième question du sondage
opinionway
est ce que vous êtes inquiet ou pas de
la montée des mouvements populistes
en europe inquiète 59% pas inquiète 39%
et vous même
en tout cas nous inquiète ne pas les
voir
inquiet oui oh oui cessez jamais une
bonne chose
enfin leurs ailes à la quelle est la
colonne vertébrale de l'homme politique
c'est pas simplement de constater ou de
bavarder c'est de prendre des décisions
ce populisme inquiétant est la
conséquence de quoi et c'est à dire tout
le grand défi qui attend la droite
française
la droite française sort d'une année
2010 est catastrophique
la droite française aujourd'hui c'est la
promesse de l'aube c'est à dire que nous
avons une immense responsabilité sur la
question européenne
prochain grand scrutin qui viennent il
ya trois façons de voir l'europe où on
considère que la situation d'aujourd'hui
est très bonne comme monsieur macro et
donc il faut plus d'europe plus
élargissement il propose l'élargissement
aux balkans plus de technocratie ça
n'est pas notre vision
la vision de madame le pen puisque ça ne
va pas on sort de l'europe
on sort de l'euro ça n'est pas notre
vision avec laurent wauquiez ne
proposerait une troisième voie une
nouvelle europe une europe nouvelle
fondée sur plus de démocratie fondée sur
l'idéal de protection nous adhérons
pleinement à une europe qui protège les
intérêts vitaux des peuples européens
les chinois les russes les américains
ont le vient de voir les sud américains
se protège seuls les européens ont du
mal à protéger avait déjà quinze jours
qu'on entend les commissaires de
bruxelles dire à on a vu l'arrêt à la
décision de monsieur trump on va bientôt
réfléchir à une volonté de nous mêmes
nous protéger l'acier l'aluminium la
sidérurgie et tous nos grands groupes
annoncent si on ne fait rien des pertes
de dizaines de milliers d'emplois enfin
une europe de l'audace et de
l'innovation moi je crois que sur le
plan marshall comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure et sur le grand défi qui nous
attend au combien passionnant de
l'intelligence artificielle
l'europe a une immense et belle
responsabilité à porter devant les
peuples
est-ce que vous tenez toujours comme
laurent wauquiez après le premier tour
de la présidentielle la balance et
gagnent entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya que vous
je ne vous je ne je pense pas du tout
comme ça j'écoute madame le pen j'écoute
monsieur macron j'écoute monsieur
mélenchon je suis passionné et amoureux
de mon pays et donc je suis
et écoute ce que disent les responsables
politiques mais avec laurent wauquiez
nous ne nous positionnons jamais en
référence des autres nous avons vocation
nous avons vocation à reprendre le
pouvoir en 2022 nous avons conquis un
certain nombre de deux bonnes nouvelles
ces dernières semaines
il nous faut continuer comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure la droite et les
républicains c'est la promesse de l'aube
il nous faut beaucoup de modestie
beaucoup d'humilité une volonté acharnée
de travail et de fédérer de redonner
envie à des gens qui nous ont quittés de
nous rejoindre et de bien leur dire que
désormais nous avons tiré les leçons des
échecs passés et que la droite c'est le
grand mouvement populaire de la france
des territoires de la france des
provinces de la france les villes
moyennes
parce que nous adressons aussi aux à
leur citadins eu la droite semble front
national on l'a bien compris mais cela
dit ce que la droite des républicains
avec marion maréchal-le pen par un jour
que ça a reçu c'est possible mais j'ai
parlé de mon des racines et des ailes
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
quelle est la valeur que je porte depuis
toujours contenu mon éducation et de mon
engagement politique
c'est la valeur du mérite ça fera
bientôt cinquante ans que la famille le
pen se présente à l'élection
présidentielle le grand père la fille un
jour la tente
c'est donc bien linverse très
précisément de ce que je vois et comment
je fonde l'engagement politique donc pas
plus l'une que l'autre
notre vision nous il est très clair les
fondée sur le mérite sur un grand
mouvement populaire capable de
rassembler tous les français et nous
nous adressons d'ailleurs en particulier
aux électeurs qui ont voté pour emmanuel
macron et qui depuis huit mois voit bien
que non plus ce qui porte le nom de ce
nom j'ai raison la dernière question
dernière minute sur la situation dans
l'île dans le département français
mayotte
voilà laurent wauquiez il était l'autre
jour brigitte girardin il est
aujourd'hui même et quand il y était
laurent wauquiez a critiqué l'inaction
du gouvernement français mais est ce que
ce qui se passe là bas c'est pas la
conséquence de la départementalisation
de mayotte qui a été décidé en 2009 2010
sous sa réponse en 30 secondes très
rapidement 30 secondes
vous savez la situation s'est aggravée
depuis 2000 12 30% de hausse des
questions de d'insécurité si vous allez
dire que les habitants sont excédés
laurent wauquiez eu raison de se rendre
sur place
soutenir notre candidat est d'alerter
les autorités françaises sur la
situation à mayotte
moi je crois qu'il fallait très loin à
mayotte françois baroin l'avait proposé
en figaro magazine en 2005 laurent
wauquiez là on a parlé la semaine
dernière
combien faudra probablement revenir les
remettre en cause de demain qui sont à
la mode merci 6 millions pelleter merci
messieurs merci merci à vous tous vont
se voir a très vite
[Musique]